[موسيقى]
قنوات تلفزيونيه متنوعه وخيارات عديده
لانشاء اتصالات بين انحاء العالم بالصوت
والصوره خرائط الطرق وتنبؤات الطقس كل ذلك
لم يكن موجودا قبل عام
1957 عندما اعلن الروس اطلاق اثباتنك اول
قمر صناعي فكيف حدث ذلك
ربما كان العالم اسحاق نيوتن الذي توفي
عام
1727 اول من فكر في الاقمار الصناعيه كما
ان وضعه لقوانين الحركه الثلاثه ووصف
الجاذبيه العامه شكل الاساسي لفهم
الصواريخ والاقمار الصناعيه والمدارات لكن
الاقمار الصناعيه في الفضاء بقيه مجرده
تصورات وضعها العلماء واحلى من في خيالي
كتاب القصص حيث نشرت الصور الخياليه
الاولى للاقمار الصناعيه في القصص القصيره
لادوارد هيل خلال القرن التاسع عشر كذلك
جاء كاتبه الخيال العلمي في عام
1945 ارثر كلارك بفكره وضع الاقمار
الصناعيه في مدارس حول الارض واستخدامها
للاتصالات في خمسينيات القرن الماضي اشتعل
التنافس بين الاتحاد السوفيتي والولايات
المتحده لاختراع الاول قمر صناعي فاطلق
الاتحاد السوفيتي القمر الصنا عام
1957 بامضاء من برودباند وريفر وكان
بمثابه البدايه لاطلاق اكثر من سته الاف
قمر في السنوات التاليه
في ديسمبر من العام نفسه خاض الامريكيون
محاوله لائسه لحميه قمر صناعي علمتني
صاروخ لكنهم نجحوا في نهايته يناير في
اطلاق القمر الصناعي اكسبلورر 1 الى مدار
الارض بسبب خطه فيرنرفون براون ما ساعدهم
ايضا على اكتشاف منطقتين مليئتين
بالجسيمات المشحونه ضمن المجال
المغناطيسيه
نجاحتهم واطلقوا برنامج لونا لاستكشاف
القمر واصبح دون اثنان اول جسم من صنع
الانسان يضرب القمر عام
1959 ونسبت لهم اول عمليه سير في الفضاء
واول شخص يدور حول الارض بمركبه فضائيه
واول رحله لامراه تسافر الى الفضاء
على جانب الاخر نجح الناس في اطلاق برنامج
قمر لاتصالات المتزامل سين كوم عام
1961 تبع ذلك اول بث مباشر عبر المحيط
الاطلسي باستخدام قمر تلستار واحد ثم
برنامج قمر زنكم ثلاثه الذي تمكن من بث
التلفزيون كما اسر الرئيس الامريكي انا
ذاك جون كينيدي اول محادثات عبر الاقمار
الصناعيه مع رئيس الوزراء النيجيري
وخلال الستينيات ايضا نجحت ناس في انزال
انسان على سطح القمر من خلال مشروع
الجوزاء قبل ان تاتي بمشروع ابولو الذي
اصبح بفضله ارمسترونج اول انسان يضع قدمه
على سطح القمر
وفي عام 1970 كسرت الصين احتكارا عالم
الفضاء عندما اطلقت الصين اول قمر صناعي
لها
منذ انتهاء برنامج ابول القمري في عام
1972 تتشارك العديد من الدول تجارب الفضاء
وتجري ابحاثا بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه كما
شهد العالم الكثير من تجارب السفر لرواد
الفضاء واكتشاف مجسات النظام الشمسي والاف
الكواكب والجسيمات
كما بات هناك اكثر من الف قمر صناعي نشاط
يدور حول الارض بعد ان كانت هذه الاقمار
مجرده احلام في صفحات قصص الخيال
[موسيقى]